agent hunt is transferring classified
files from the CIA mainframe into his
flash drive this is the formula for the
size of the files on agent hunts drive s
measured in megabytes as a function of
time T measured in seconds complete the
following sentences with the appropriate
missing values when the transfer began
the drive had blank megabytes of files
on it so when the transfer began that
would be T equals zero T equals zero was
right when the transfer began so T
equals zero s of 0 s of 0 is going to be
5 times 0 5 times 0 plus 45 which of
course is just going to be equal to 45
and s is measured and they tell us
measured in megabytes so there were 45
megabytes of files on his on his drive
before or right when the transfer began
then they say every 10 seconds every 10
seconds an additional blank megabytes
are transferred into the drive so every
10 seconds how many well one way to
think about there's a bunch of ways you
could think about this one is well we
know that there were 45 megabytes at
time equals 0 well let's think about
what happens 10 seconds later how many
megabytes are in his drive
so we could say s of 10 is going to be 5
times 10 plus 45 which is equal to 50
plus 45 so at time equals 0 there were
45 megabytes and it and 10 seconds later
there's now 50 plus 45 megabytes so in
10 seconds an extra 50 megabytes are
transferred into the drive and that's
that's expected because as T increases 1
this function goes up by 5 so if T
increases by 10 this is going to
increase by 50 so for every 10 seconds
you would have 50 megabytes are
transferred in the drive and you could
test that more if you want you can say
ok let's we go another 10 seconds s of
20 seconds that's going to be 5 times 20
plus
45 which is equal to 100 plus 45 so
notice when 10 seconds have passed in
time when we've increased time by 10
seconds we've increased memory our
memory that we're using the megabytes
we're using has increased by has
increased by has increased by 50